>> We have one more
speaker for today,
I'm very excited to
introduce to you,
and that is Albert Greenberg.
Albert is the Corporate Vice
President at Microsoft.
He's in the Azure
Networking Group which is
the team that develops engineers,
and runs all of the systems and
tools that power
the Microsoft Cloud Network.
He is well-known as an author
and a researcher himself.
Multiple awards including
a SIGMETRICS Test of Time Award.
He's a veteran of
both Bell Labs and AT&T,
where he was a principal
in developing a lot of
the systems and tools that
AT&T used to run its network,
and has done foundational work in
developing the architectures and
systems that are part of
software-defined networking.
So, Albert joined us in 2007.
He joined the Azure team,
I should say Microsoft
Research in 2007.
He joined the Azure team in 2010,
and he's here with us tonight.
So with that, thank you for
joining, Albert Greenberg.
>> Thank you. Hi. So, it's
a pleasure to talk to
you about startups.
The startup that we're on
is doubling every year,
and it's an amazing journey.
By the way, thank you for coming.
I see a lot of faces
that I recognized in
the audience and we have
a beautiful new space.
You'll find that we're open
and I'd like to see you more
often than just in this room,
and hopefully, spend
more time with you.
So, I'm going to try and
describe the challenge
of building a Cloud
and the expectations that
we have for the Cloud.
It's really exciting to
be on this journey
to build the Cloud.
We see it as the platform for
all the world's computing.
It's a very inspiring task
to build and we see
so much workload pouring on at
mission-critical workloads,
hospitals, police forces.
Interacting with groups like that
where they take reliability
super seriously
inspires us to even take
it more seriously
and understand what
they mean by reliability and
then embody that in our DNA.
So, I'm going to talk about
reliability and convince you,
I hope, that reliability is
the coolest thing that
you could work on.
Let's see, is that go?
Okay. So, one thing that at
Microsoft we do and
I do in every one of
my staff meetings,
and every one of
our technical meetings
is talk about not just deep tech
but deep culture.
So, I'm going to do that here
and I'm not going to
bury it at the end.
I want to talk about culture on
the first slide. Do
a little bit of that.
Then I'll talk about
the Open Platform
we're building for
the Research Community,
and then give you some view
of what Azure scale means,
and what it means to build
a mission-critical platform for
all applications on the planet,
and how would that
cause us to rethink
things on networking,
and what an amazing
opportunity we
have to rethink and
rebuild networks.
I'll just pick two things.
I'll pick how we rethink device
firmware and how we rethink
design and operations.
Okay. So, let me talk
a little bit about culture.
Again, we take it super
seriously and we talk
about it all the time,
and the connection to reliability
is clear that monocultures
are risky, right?
Monocultures people believe in
the same vision and
they agree with each other
and they get it wrong,
and I've seen it again and again.
Diversity in our team
delivers creativity,
innovation, and lowers risk.
So, yeah, I talk about
diversity all the time.
We have a long ways to
go in our industry,
but also the encouraging thing
is we're putting a focus on it.
So, for example, when
we spin up new teams
and new initiatives,
we'd set as a target 40
percent diverse hires,
and we hit it.
So, we can do it and it's great,
it's working out for us.
We're not there yet, we're
trying to get better,
but wanted to give
you that update.
>> My favorite aspect
of working on
the open network and
UMD user interface,
was that I got to
learn how to use
AngularJS in the building
of a website.
The great communication
and unity of my team
was what help to perfect
my skills that I have learned.
>> Microsoft project was
an interesting blend of
formal verification
and emulation.
I love the fact that
I could work at
the intersection of
cutting-edge research and
engineering that to add
an Azure scale and that's
what excites me the
most and brought me back
in a full-time role here on
the Open Network Emulator.
>> I should have given
you a little bit of
preamble before
showing the video,
but that was a video
of an intern we have
now and an intern that,
I think I saw her in the room,
that created the emulator
that I'll tell you about.
So, one thing that we want to do
is encourage you to
collaborate with us,
work with us, and continue
to send us interns.
I can tell you in my team alone,
we're hiring 90,
nine-zero college hires,
that's our target in the U.S.,
and more in other places
around the world.
Okay. So, we spent just 7.5
billion recently for
a company called GitHub.
We are committed to Open Source
and this is just the,
what we call
the NASCAR diagram of
the different Open
Source products we have.
I was glad to see Databricks.
Databricks is one of
the customers and they are also
based on an Open Source Project.
So we are, it's
the new Microsoft,
we're open, we love Linux,
we love Open Source.
I think the GitHub acquisition
speaks 7.5 billion times.
So, one thing I want
to announce here today
really is the the
open sourcing of
an emulator that I'll
tell you about called the
Open Network Emulator (One)
and it's a little bit
of a pre-announce,
it'll be available January, 2019,
and I'll tell you
about what it provides
for you and I hope
it'll excite you.
It'll provide you a way to really
emulate Cloud scale and I'll tell
you what I mean by
emulation in a minute,
and it provides
hands-on experience for
students on the real
router software.
I'm talking about thousands
of routers and switches in
Real Networks and create
large-scale labs on-demand.
Test your next research
idea and go as
deep as you want in building
networks and they're
the real networks,
but you don't have
to buy the hardware.
You can run all this stuff
on the Cloud, our Cloud.
So, and this emulator
supports both commercial.
Now, the normal sets of
companies that you think
have been networking and our own
Open-Source switch
firmware called SONiC.
The word virtual's in here,
it's the real thing, it's not
modelling or something like that,
it's the actual
software that runs on
the device and it'll be
available in the marketplace.
Just start it, portal.azure.com,
and you'll find it, and
there's the contact.
By the way, I'm
albert@research- no,
I'm albert@microsoft.com,
excuse me.
And you can email me
for other things, okay.
So, let me tell you
a little bit- Azure scale,
Mark Russinovich may have
gone through some of this.
What it means, these
numbers I have to
update all the time,
because if we keep growing,
I think the left at
the bottom of Africa,
we just added some new
data centers and regions.
We're in 54 Azure regions,
we're all over the earth.
We've deployed 70,000 miles
of fiber in 103 locations.
We have 130 global edge slides.
These are the outer ring
close to the metros,
where we can reach
the rest of the internet.
Just a fun fact that we think,
that we are such a large
network we deploy
more technology than
any Telco you can think of
and probably any cloud
you can think of.
So, we deployed more for example,
100 g dense wavelength division
multiplexing links this year
than the rest of
the industry combined.
So, we are building
a huge network.
Areas of innovation,
one that I'll talk
about today is we take
an algorithm and
data-driven approach
to network design and
operations and it's deep.
It's not us modeling on the side,
it's in the guts and
the actual mechanism how we
run and design the network.
We innovate
an optical technology,
this thing would have
been cost prohibitive
if we had just used off
the shelf technology
and we innovate
in our own software
defined network.
I hope some of you or
your interns get a chance
to visit one of
our data centers just to
get an idea of the scale.
It's an incredible scale,
so there's Dave Malts and
that little car down there
with a circle around
it, just kidding.
But that's the scale thing
there and there's
the big data center
it's enormous scale
and that's just one of
the data centers in the region.
In terms of mission critical,
again I'm going to talk
to you about reliability.
We support 90 percent of
the Fortune 500 on
the Microsoft cloud.
These are just some
of the names but it
just brings home
that reliability is so key.
These people haven't just taken
their small test labs
or something like that
and put it in the cloud,
they put their core business
in the cloud because it
doesn't make sense to build
it on prem and they
support the- lot of things
are born in the cloud and
other things are connected
to the to the premise but
this is how these companies
build and run their their world
and its how again
the critical government and
medical infrastructure
runs the world.
Right, so we connect to a lot of,
we have a private
connectivity offer
that is taking off like crazy.
Where you want to have
one relationship with Microsoft
with different access providers.
These are some of the access
provided where you can get
private connectivity straight to
the Microsoft Cloud and
this chart is also growing.
So, we reach everybody with
high-speed privately
and an over internet.
This is just something I often
show and we believe in Azure.
Now, what is the hierarchy
of needs for the cloud?
What are the basic things?
It's all about, at the bottom
you have to be secure,
if you're not secure then you
won't trust running your your
critical apps in the cloud.
So, that's at the very
bottom and we spent
a lot of time on
security constantly.
Reliability is one
I'll talk about today.
It has to be supportable,
you have to be able to
just use it and it has to
just work with that a lot of
thinking and trying to figure
it out calling us up and
it has to work the way you
expect it and it has to be fast.
So those are my priorities
and in this talk, talk
about reliability.
I'll talk about just two,
there's a wide set of
work on reliability,
but I'll talk about the device
firmware and talking about Sonic
which is on GitHub
and I'll talk about
the network emulator
also on GitHub.
Will be on GitHub
for you to download.
Okay, let me start with Sonic.
So, if you think
about the world of
networks it's changing
in a very exciting way.
So, it had been that you'd buy
this monolithic box from
a networking vendor
and all the things
that I highlight here in
blue you would not have.
You really want to run
your networking and consume
your software the way you do
cloud and other
computing artifacts.
You don't want
a big proprietary box that
you can't change and grow.
So, you want agility,
you want to be able to- we,
in the cloud we ship weekly.
When there's a bug we take
care of the bug right away
within hours or as fast as
we can roll it out bug fix.
It has to be serviceable.
There's something that I don't
know if academia studies enough.
Serviceability it's so critical.
You have to be able to update,
it goes with reliability
and the velocity.
You have to be able to
update without anybody
noticing you have to be able
to update all the time.
Things have to be modular,
so you can do these Hitler's
upgrades and restart.
It has to be as simple as use
a normal sort of container
update to reload the OS image.
It has to be something
you can already
do and reliable up which
I've talked about.
So, two things here,
one is, we're getting
a lot of help from
the industry so there are
these companies that are
producing amazing
merchants silicon.
These are ASICs that
are fairly cheap and
can do everything you'd
like to do in networking,
they have super high speed,
they have lots of ports,
they have the right kind
of buffering,
they have incredible
capabilities hidden.
You may not know about
them but the ASIC supports
them and if you can
just get access to
that ASIC and at the same time
you want to protect,
you want to protect your software
that runs above that ASICs,
you need some sort of hardware
abstraction layer that
allows you to plug
in any ASIC below,
your software keeps working.
But you can still get to
the unique features
of the basic below.
We have something called switch
abstraction interface
which provides
that and I'll tell you
it's really working out.
So we can we don't have to go
with just one ASIC vendor,
we can go with several.
It's again Open-Source,
go to GitHub, pick it up.
It's Open-Source,
it's supported through
the Open Compute Platform.
Provides essentially the.H
files for your code.
Common APIs which are then
implemented by drivers beneath
it depending on the ASIC.
It supports disaggregation
you don't have to buy
this monolith you can get
the ASIC by the board,
get the whole thing
manufactured and build
your own router.
And so, the software and
hardware can evolve independently
and there's an open
community around it.
So, above this SAI,
we have something
which was definitely
named in a different way
so you would
remember it called SONiC,
and that's the software
that really operates
the switch and that's
what we use in Azure.
So, it's also
available through OCP,
it provides everything you
need in terms of functionality.
I'll tell you
a little bit more but
it really allows you to
run your network devices like
you'd run a Cloud service,
like you'd run
software in general,
yet you can do networking.
So, it really opens up
the world to be able to
change things and get at
the power of these ASICs
and really enjoy
the disaggregation that
the industry is providing.
So here, this is just the kind of
network we build to support
our regional networks.
It's a class style network,
classes at Bell Labs
mathematician in the 50's that
figured this stuff out
and did a good job.
So, there's a lot
of regularity here,
a lot of power here.
So, it's like RAID for networks,
you have lots of components.
Things can fail, it's okay
because you've got
more things that are working,
yet you can have
a full bisection bandwidth.
Basically, you can
go from any point in
a region to any other point
without congestion.
You need software running on
those switches and that's
where we run SONiC.
So it shows the SONiC
software there.
Now one test of you're
really managing
your software like you would
manage software services,
just stuff works that
you'd expect to work.
Like down at the bottom,
there's RedisDB.
It can be any kind of
caching service you want.
So, in networking, the very
simplest things like getting
counters out of a box,
in the old school world there's
this protocol called SNMP.
Back in the day, 20 years ago
when it was invented
it was awesome,
but now every time you want
a single column in
SNMP the ITF meets,
maybe they don't accept
or maybe they do.
Maybe you beg your vendor
to get it in,
maybe they do, maybe they don't.
It's just counters,
what's the big deal?
So, you can just reflect,
you can put a Redis agent
on the switch
and it can just export
whatever counters you need,
and push-pull,
all those options are yours.
So, there's the typical
networking applications
on top of the operating
system, as well as,
orchestration software and
telemetry software: Ansible,
which we use, Puppet,
Chef, and so forth.
So, we wouldn't do
this project if it didn't
improve reliability.
So today, we don't have
control if we go to
a commercial vendor.
We're convincing,
we're building
the world's biggest Cloud,
we have big pockets,
wallets, or something.
But we can't control
the quality of what
goes in that software.
SONiC gives us that control,
and then really, it's still
hard work, software's hard.
But we don't support
every feature,
we just support what's needed
for the Cloud applications.
So, we minimize the baggage
that goes along.
Then we're free to
pick and choose,
cherry pick what what software
we want to go with,
and every Cloud provider
that consumes SONiC
and every one of you,
if you can send SONiC
can pick your software.
Hit this upgrade is huge for us,
we want to be able if there's
a bug take care of it,
if there's a feature we
want take care of it
without you as
a customer noticing.
So, we can fix bugs and do fleet
wide security patches in hours
and new features in days.
Yeah, we put the pressure
of the entire cloud on
the software so it's battle
tested. Open Source.
So, it's working out, as I said,
we have a lot of community.
We've spent time on community
in the top right hand
corner of some of
the companies that are also
heavily invested in SONiC.
We work with the other companies
to run their software
in the SONiC framework.
In the middle right,
my right, companies
that do the ODM world.
They build the devices
that make up the
hardware of the switch.
As well as on the left
middle, the OEM world,
some of them anyway
like ARISTA that build
a device and sell it directly.
Then below, we have
all these ASIC manufacturers
and Cisco as well,
all part of the community.
So, really it's
an invitation to you.
If you like networking
or you think you might
like networking,
you want to experiment
networking,
you can consume SONiC.
It's very pleasant I think,
it's containerized, it's Docker,
and it's familiar, it's Linux.
It's what you know how to do,
you can just consume
it and make it work.
So, try it.
You can find it by
web search or you can just
remember this GitHub URL.
So, I'm going to change now from,
we did this network firmware
because they wanted
greater control,
we wanted to improve reliability,
and we wanted to take care
of all the bugs themselves.
We wanted just the features
we needed to improve
reliability but let's now
think about the big network.
Let's think, how do
we build a network
that is reliable by design
and meet these goals,
changes work as intended,
is resilient, we minimize
the impact of changes,
it learns and adapts
automatically,
and we can verify
with formal methods
any gap between what we intend
the network to do and
what it actually does.
You saw all those links there,
there could be little
defects in the optics,
we have to be able to detect
these little defects.
Needle in a haystack
type problems
where we use machine learning.
So, we have a set of
projects and a set of
collaborations with
Microsoft Research.
In fact, all this
stuff that I talked
about was either born
out of or worked,
we worked together with
Microsoft Research
to bring to Azure.
I will talk about the top one
and maybe the second one.
But email me, again,
it's Albert@Microsoft.com and I
can give you the pointers
to all the others.
So, this is another slide
about some of the
challenges that we face.
If we need a fiber
nowadays or we need more
capacity between two points,
we redesign that whole thing.
We run a boat, we pulled
the fire across the ocean.
Our team does that.
So, we take on that,
it's about as routine as
you might say plug in
an Ethernet cable.
We run the boat, pull
the fiber, and we're ready.
But we have to be resilient
to storms, typhoons.
Fibers somehow gets
the sharks excited,
they like to bite the fiber.
There's repeaters down there.
Sadly, there's
fishing that catches
the cables and there's
potentially sabotage.
So, it costs a lot of
money to run the boat out,
to pull the fiber up, fix it,
and sink it back down.
So, we think a lot about
optimizing for resilient design
so that we don't have
to rush the boat out.
We have enough fiber in
the right places that
it's okay if some of
these disasters happen.
Netsim is one of the projects
that allows us to
understand the impact of
any failure on the fiber.
Okay. So, let me
tell you about that
a little bit and then I'll get on
to the one network emulator.
So, one theme that I want to
convey is that a lot
of the stuff we do in
networking to make the network
reliable is stuff that you
cannot do without a Cloud.
The amount of hours and
the computational methods we
apply are Cloud methods and
we need VM hours to do this.
So, we simulate-
these are modeling,
like math models simulations
of the network
covering literally millions of
contingencies for every fiber
of things that could go wrong,
there's a pipeline
here and timelines.
So, think about if you use Azure,
you're running Azure Batch
every time you think of
a project and you pretty much,
and this is what
the Cloud job is all about,
you try to anticipate
all the things that
could possibly go wrong.
Get that risk into the model and
then simulate all these things
and see if you're
resilient to them.
That's just routine for us.
We run these simulations
before we touch
the network and before and
as we design the network.
Here's an example, we
created a fiber path with
partners and it's a bit
unusual that it lands
in Spain most of them
land north of Spain.
But it was, we want diversity,
so we landed in Spain and so,
we run it from the Virginia,
DC area into Spain.
Just in this case,
we had to think about,
as we design this thing,
thousands of different
possible combinations
of ways to design and protect
the fiber and minimize
disruption as we went,
and for that, we ran
the NetSim simulator.
So, it has lots of cool videos
on the net that you can
look for Marea Cable and
you'll see different
government officials
and Microsoft Official
talking about this cable.
You can also find
deep technical talks from
my team on how we
built this cable.
Now, I'm going to talk to
you about the kind of work,
it's more detailed work.
The kind of work that happens
day to day in
operating a network.
It's not a bad analogy to think
about flying
an interesting plane,
except while the plane is flying,
you're changing the plane
and you're adding engines,
and taking away engine, and
the wings and wheels are
also changing and so forth.
So it's an evolving
plane in flight.
But the consequences again,
the reliability, it's
got to be there.
The reliability
constraints is so strong,
there is no way that plane can go
down or even be disrupted.
We need an emulator, we
need to train our people,
we need to have the kind
of confidence that
when they're making
a change to the network,
and really, people's lives
and work depend on it.
That it's going to work, and so,
we need something like
a flight simulator.
So, we built one, and
I will tell you
a little bit about it.
This is the open source thing
that you can consume
starting in January.
You can simulate
a network with fidelity,
you won't be able to tell.
You can bring in your network
engineer and let them
go at it and give them
a kind of a touring test.
Is this the Emulator or
just the the real thing?
They won't know.
You can do that with
1,000 devices in minutes.
It's seamless, it's
easy to deploy,
and it's again, high-fidelity.
So, do we use it?
We spent 12 million core hours
on Azure Network Emulator.
Before I came here,
we were running it
for a big network
migration we had to do.
By the way, because of
this emulator and
the confidence it gave us,
we did more network migrations.
We changed everything
in our network.
We pulled more cables,
we changed more routers
and switches,
we did more stuff to
the network in the last year
than we've ever done before.
It was probably
the biggest network migration
in anybody's history
and nobody noticed.
But we caught 100 or so bugs
in this Emulator,
and that's why nobody noticed.
The bugs never got to production.
So, the way it works is,
the network engineer describes
a change in a
machine-readable form.
We automatically,
could pick what vendor
software we want,
if it's the actual vendor
software and our own software,
then we download it into
the Emulated Replica and run it.
We also use theorem
proving technology from
MSR as well as the emulation,
and we find out if the intent
worked as we expected,
the intended change.
So let me try to
click through this.
I don't have time
to simulate myself.
Okay, so one problem you have
with these emulations is,
how big a network to emulate.
Where's the boundary? Are you
going to go for
the whole internet?
Where do you draw the line?
Do you have to do
the whole data center?
Well, you need this fidelity,
you need to be able to
answer the question that,
is this change safe?
Is it going to have
the intended impact?
So, part of the research
on this had been,
how do I draw
the smallest boundary?
So I can answer the question
without emulating
the entire internet,
and that's what we do.
So, we pick the economic
frontier and emulate inside it,
and we do that all the time,
and that's described in
an SOSP paper from this year.
Okay. Let me say
one other thing about it.
So, again I wanted to tell
you how high-fidelity this,
if you imagine like
you're an engineer in
one of these device companies,
you don't expect your software to
sort of go to sleep
and wake up in the
cloud and still work,
it expects, hey, I've device,
and I've got these wires,
and I'm going to
check the health of
those wires and run
some diagnostics.
All that has to work.
It has that software has to
be faked out, and fooled,
and understand that
the emulated hardware
is just like the real hardware,
and that's what happens here.
So that's part of the interesting
engineering problems.
Why does that work?
It's because of the cloud,
is because of virtual machines,.
Same deal with virtual machines.
Virtual machines think
they're on real machines,
is because of virtual networking.
So, we had to figure
out all that tech,
that's why it works now,
it didn't work five years
ago, or ten years ago.
We have the mechanisms
because we can
virtualize everything to
full-fidelity in the cloud.
We can also virtualize
the networks into this emulator,
and then use the Cloud to run
the emulator. That's
why it works.
So again, try it,
you can email the developers now
to get early information about
it and it will be on the
on Azure market place.
So this is an open invitation
for all the work.
Try sonic, try
the emulator. All right.
I think the appendix,
which I'm not going to get to,
has to do with
all those other products
we don't have time for.
It's really an
exciting opportunity
to rethink the basics
of networking.
I don't know how to directly,
or somehow chemically,
or viscerally convince you
that reliability is
the most cool thing to work on,
the most important
thing to work on.
But, if you start to think
about changing all of
computing to run in the cloud,
and then just recourse on that,
and think about,
what does that mean?
All the startups,
all the already started Apps,
all the work that you see
pouring in cloud, all them,
AI machine learning,
then you'll see
that reliability is really
a hard problem and deep
and takes years of work,
and we need you to
help us get there.
All right, I'll wrap it up.
>> Thanks Albert.
>> All right. Thanks.
>> Thank you again Albert.
It's amazing when you
consider the scale of
challenges and opportunity in
networking that you're
representing today.
Hopefully, that gives you
some potentially interesting
point as to how to pursue
your own research as well as to
guide research and instruction
for your students.
So we are at the end of day one.
Thank you for a fabulous day.
I hope it was worthwhile,
I hope you enjoyed it.
Just take a moment
before we head off
to what I expect to be
a really nice dinner
tonight at the hotel.
I want to give you a little bit
of a recap of what we've
done in a preview of what
will happen tomorrow.
So, I was really happy
that we were able to
announce here for
the first time today and
to give you input to
some new fellowship
opportunities,
both the Student Fellowship
as well as invite
your input to the Young
Faculty Fellowships,
which we'll be
bringing back soon.
I appreciated the fact that
Albert was pre-announcing
for you all the Open
Network Emulator One,
that'll be available in
January and hopefully,
you caught the email address
if you'd like to get a hold
of that ahead of time.
We had a lot of
really top-notch plenary and
breakout sessions today.
I was super pleased
with those, and again,
thanks to all of the people who
prepared so well to
deliver on that.
I hope you had an opportunity
to enjoy some break time and
to network both with
old friends and to
make some new friends.
So, we have more of this
to come again tomorrow.
Tomorrow we'll be
doing much the same,
we have a one interesting thing
though that we will add to.
Tomorrow we have
a technology showcase,
which is actually
going to be across
the hallway tomorrow.
It's a bit of a poster session.
This show directly some
of our researchers and the
projects that they're working on.
Gives you an opportunity to
engage directly with them.
We'll introduce you to those very
broadly and what we
call a lightning round,
where we'll have and
come up and give you
just one minute overview,
so you can get both the breadth
of what we're doing,
as well as have
the opportunity to engage
deeply with the researchers and
the projects that
we highlight there.
Tonight, I'm looking forward
to joining you all at dinner.
Harry Shum will be there,
Eric Roberts of course
will be hosting.
There will be a bag
check at the hotel.
So when you get there, if
you're not staying at the hotel,
you want to use a bag check,
there's a bag check their.
Buses will be be out front,
we've got a couple of buses
that are specially marked,
that have a trivia
contest on them.
So if you particularly,
want to or
don't want to be doing
trivia on the ride home.
I had two jobs as I said,
one of which was
the weather which I'm
hopeful it is still
going well out there.
You know there was traffic.
I'm still working on that, but
maybe Albert can help me with
some of the traffic management
that we have to do.
But I am looking forward
to dinner tonight,
we'll hopefully have
you as well for
a group photo tonight, so
it'll be a lot of fun.
One other way I'd love
for us to be able to
say thank you to you is
when you do check in,
we'd love to provide you
with a new smart speaker.
So we've got the Harman/
Kardon invoke plus
Cortana speaker as
a gift for you also.
Thank you again for
joining us here today.
The buses are out front,
we will be back here at
08:30 in the morning.
If you enjoyed what
you heard today,
be sure to communicate
with us on all of
those properties.
Hashtag is MS facts some.
We'll see you at dinner
tonight and here again
tomorrow morning at 08:30.
Thanks for a great first day.